[موسيقى
] لقد
قمت بأشياء وجربت أشياء في
المنزل
لم أستمتع بها في العادة ولكن
الوقت
أو الطاقة لأعرفها خاصة
مع أطفالي ،
أنت تعلم عندما تلعب كل
ثلاثة أيام خلال  في الأساس طوال حياتك
المهنية ،
ليس لديك الكثير من الوقت لهذه
الأشياء الصغيرة ، يبدو الأمر
سخيفًا ولكنك تعلم أن هذه هي القليل من
الملذات التي تعلم
أنك تقدرها بمجرد حصولك
عليها وأنا
أعلم أن الفيروس قد أثر على عائلتك
شخصيًا.
الجدة العظيمة تصاب
بالفيروس وتعيش في عمر 95
عامًا ، يجب أن تكون امرأة رائعة ، نعم
إنه أمر لا يصدق للغاية ، واليوم كانت تبلغ من
العمر 96 عامًا اليوم ، كانت إيجابية مرتين
وقد تخلصت
من الموقف مرتين حتى تعرف أننا
فخورون جدًا بها وهي  إنها تبدو
جيدة وصحية لأننا نشكر الله على
أننا نمر
بصراحة فترة غير عادية من
التغيير
هذا العام ما رأيك في استجابة كرة القدم
في الأشهر الأخيرة
لـ k  لقد كان رد فعل جورج
فلويد وحركة حياة السود
أمرًا قويًا للغاية ،
وأعتقد أنه يتعين علينا الاحتفاظ بها على هذا النحو ، كما
تعلم
عندما أسمع مثل رحيم ستيرلينج راشفورد
هؤلاء الرجال أنهم أساطير
هم الأشخاص الذين يتعين علينا الاستماع إليهم
لأنك تعلم أنهم يقولون ذلك كما
هو وتتعلم الكثير
من هؤلاء الشباب وأنت تعلم
أنهم قدوة للمجتمع ولنا جميعًا
كم مرة شاهدت فيها حوادث عنصرية
في حياتك المهنية إما مباشرة
ضد زملائك في الفريق أو
لحسن الحظ بالنسبة لي ، لم أرها
وجهاً لوجه في المدرجات ولكن من الواضح نعم لقد
سمعتها في الملاعب في
بعض الأحيان لا تدرك ذلك
لأنك تركز
كما تعلم على اللعبة وبعض اللاعبين
سيقولون لك انظروا ماذا هم  تغني ،
انظروا إلى ما
يقولونه وأنتم مثل يا إلهي ، أنت تعلم أن
هذا أمر مروع ،
ما هو الحاجة إلى وجود الكثير من الأشخاص ،
آه الأطفال
يشاهدون الألعاب وهم يحلمون
بإحضار
ابني في نهاية كل أسبوع لمشاهدة كرة القدم
ه  كل يوم سبت كل يوم أحد ،
وإذا رأيت هذه الأشياء ، فلن
تفعل ذلك ، فلن أفعل ذلك إذا رأيت
التوقف